-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
According to a new report,
some of President Biden's
top allies are quietly meeting
with Democratic officials
and donors
ahead of the 2024 election
in case he doesn't run.
Well, quietly,
aside from the person
who keeps coughing the word
"Hillary."
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
met today with
Ukrainian First Lady
Olena Zelenska
at the White House.
"Sorry for everything your
country is going through,"
said Zelenska.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk was photographed
over the weekend
aboard a luxury yacht
in Mykonos, Greece,
and all I can say is wow!
He is...
He is so white,
the sun had to put on sunscreen!
[ Laughter ]
He looks like
the page in the coloring book
you haven't gotten to yet.
[ Laughter ]
Is he partying on that yacht...
or is he haunting it?
[ Laughter ]
I will say, though --
I will say, he does have
the skin tone of somebody who
is very good with technology.
[ Laughter ]
Steven Spielberg recently
directed his first music video
using his smartphone,
which is surprising
because most people his age
record concerts on their iPads.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
a couple who has been married
for nearly 80 years
said that their secret
to a long-lasting relationship
is always sharing a kiss
before bedtime.
"Same," said those freaks
from "Willy Wonka."
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Kathy Hochul
announced yesterday
she will expand
shark-patrol crews
amid an increase
of attacks on Long Island.
Meanwhile, Republican governors
are encouraging residents
to buy sharks for protection.
[ Laughter ]
The only thing
that stops a shark
is a good guy with a shark.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
11% of Americans said that
their favorite ice-cream flavor
is vanilla.
Well, if you love vanilla,
I got good news for you!
There it is!
That was a monologue, you guys.